[Music]
I am by no means the first person to
point out that the agricultural
revolution was a disaster for human
beings
lots of scholars before me have made the
similar point this is very important
because the agricultural revolution
takes place at the same time as the
Neolithic Revolution right it's seen as
this massive jump in human evolution
where we stopped hunting and gathering
and we began planting and harvesting
instead and the common sense theory is
that this was a good thing for a
humanity that it increased our food
supply that it allowed us to actually
settle and create villages it
essentially was the first step to
creating what we know as civilization
unfortunately the data does not back
that up on the contrary we now know due
to studies of skeletons around the time
of the Neolithic Revolution that human
beings actually ended up consuming fewer
calories and certainly fewer proteins
during the Agricultural Revolution than
they did when we were hunter-gatherers
we've discovered that the process of
farming actually created a whole range
of new and at that time absolutely novel
diseases and problems with with human
beings I mean you know as one scholar
put it the Homo Sapien body is not
designed for planting it's designed for
hunting and it was there were enormous
costs to that transition so there been a
lot of speculation about why the
transition some have argued that it's
because of climactic reasons that there
was a massive shift of climate that
essentially compelled people to begin
planting there's really no evidence to
prove that point some have said that
it's because there was a a sudden drop
in the number of species that were
available to be hunted there's again no
real evidence
of that at all this is one of those
moments again where we just don't know
why but I present what I think is a
fairly novel theory one that others have
discussed before which is that the
reason we stopped hunting and gathering
and started farming instead was because
of religion and in this particular case
institutionalized religion the argument
goes back to a site in southeastern
Turkey called gobekli tepe this is as
far as we know the oldest temple to have
ever been unearthed it's about twelve to
fourteen thousand years old it's a
massive temple in the middle of you know
a desert region a place where no one
lived so we know that this was a place
of religious significance a place that
was not habitable that people came from
all over the the land to actually take
part in some kind of devotional activity
at this temple and we also know that the
building of this temple coincided with
the first signs of agriculture in that
region the theory is complex but in the
simplest way it's that in order to
essentially feed the workers who built
this massive temple over the course of
many many decades and then in order to
feed what would have been perhaps
thousands of people who would come to
this temple in order to actually take
part in the devotions there it was
necessary to come up with food surplus
options one of those ideas was to take
the naturally growing stalks of wheat
and barley that were growing around the
region and to start actually planting
them with purpose another idea was to
instead of hunting animals killing them
and then feasting upon them to actually
capture the animals bring them back
penned them and then slaughter them as
needed the archaeological evidence
indicates that this was where the first
real experiments with what we would now
refer to as farming in domestication
took place and so the theory is that it
wasn't climate change or a depletion of
natural resources that resulted in the
decision to begin planting and
domesticating that rather it was the
imposition of institutional religion
that did that
[Music]